so welcome everyone to my talk about how
to boost your web development efficiency
some of the stuff was already set by
Martin before because we have some
overlapping topic called lineage but as
I'm sure you will still have some value
out of this presentation what I did is I
tried to compile all the most important
tools that I use in my web development
and I also have like my settings my
configuration objects directly in the
presentation and everything is linked to
online so you can check out the slides
after the talk and you can do the
configurations yourself so the first
topic is already lint staged so lean
stage this basically a wrapper around
get hooks so it makes it more easily
usable for you and like a good hook you
could imagine it like being an angular
lifecycle hook so like ng underneath and
she on changes whatever and it's
especially useful for doing a pre-commit
hook so let's say you you and some
colleagues of you fight over the code
style and there's always like he leaves
some white spaces in there and you
remove them again and it's like a
constant back and forth so with like a
pre-commit hook where you say ok we use
this tool to format our code and you can
always be sure that you only have really
clean code and only changes that are
relevant another possibility would be to
use a pre push hook so let's say you
want to push something online and you
want to push it to your CLI and you
always fear that your pipeline gonna
fail your pipeline gonna fail this would
be one way of maybe avoiding it so you
would let your unit test and your enter
in test run before you push it yeah mmm
so this would actually be a package like
I you can also make like a lean staged
RC config file to have it encapsulated
but I implemented here in the package
Jason first settings I used here is
concurrent for subtest concurrency 1
this is used because I had the problems
that because this linters run at the
same time that sometimes the format I
went over it and changed files but it
didn't add them to the to the actual
commit so the commit went through
and then there were some leftover
changes in the in the actual branch
so this refusing only substance
concurrency one it's a wallet at problem
yeah for HTML files I use the auto
format HTML script you can see it down
here it's using TS lint with the fixed
flag so the fixed flag already tries to
fix as many issues as possible that it
can do by itself and then also it takes
the project wide configuration that use
convict a Singh and T is Lin chasin for
the t's Lin rules for CSS and chairs I
just use prettier because that was
seemed like the obvious and easy choice
to make and for the typescript I use
something that is called clang format so
this might not be the obvious choice
like we heard before you can use
prettier but for me it seemed that
prettier like it a prettier also wants
to be like easy and it doesn't give you
many customization options on purpose
but I was like ok with the typescript
with the types to Portugal want to be
able to change everything to my own
needs mm-hmm yeah and then it goes
through and uses the lint script and
yeah I already explained T's and what's
also there is like the ignore so for
minified files of course you don't want
it to be reformatted into an unmeaning
fide version so yeah about Auto
formatting typescript like prettier type
script format client format these are
free could be free possible options I
looked at them and for me it was obvious
to use clang format it's actually used
for C++ and C sharp formatting but it
works perfectly fine for typescript what
I did here is at first I started using
Google style and that was the the base
to work with but then step-by-step I
started being not happy with it and I
basically rewrote everything here so
this is definitely oh I have this one
this is definitely not necessary here
so I could at some point I would
probably clean this up a little bit to
have
the necessary rules what I also like
about Clank format is that it in sorts
your imports by specific criteria what I
mean with criteria here is that's going
to be various code here in my main
browser TS you can see it easily
so what clang format then does it's like
when you have the four module import it
puts them at the top of your file then
it leaves a blank space then it imports
your dependencies out of the package
jason and then like down below here it
would use your relative imports you also
you can always be sure where your
imports are or you can see it usually
are with a single look and yeah i wrote
here showcase time so i prepared already
staged changes so I actually made my
file it's this readable for your sugar
yeah sure [ __ ] which one - no this one
oh yeah much better ok so yeah you can
see a factory it up pretty good I [ __ ]
it up here I yeah the constructor stuff
is an indented and here for example
forces on the next line the the closing
place of the F is on the same light of
the line of the code stuff like that so
it's quite horrible and what I would do
now is like used actuals this the actual
script so I would say Auto format ts
goes for the tree and the I flag is for
interactive replacing it back in the
editor you would see here I have now my
changes here and if we're lucky it
should be yeah it should be back in its
place so nice and clean everything again
and like stuff like this here for
example to credit relief wrap aligned
underneath each other was a pain in the
ass so it was a very it was quite a work
to go through this Clank format and look
at all the options that there are yeah
same of course we can do for the
like here we have a details page an HTML
page and you see that the h3 here is
wrong and this one is just in the same
line and also really horrible so
therefore we have the HTML formatting
yeah it outputs also unchanged files but
it should have fixed this one yeah you
see now the h3 is aligned on yeah sorry
who I didn't try that out I'm not using
any Indian templates but that would be
interesting yeah but I guess it probably
won't work because you're looking for
the wild card ts so probably not but
here you see it's back to normal and
should be fine and then also have here
my shame CSS file and it also is you
know what a shame CSS file is okay yeah
so you have a lot of stuff here also
have been wrong formerly in the entered
and stuff oh sorry
so I would go back here again and do it
with node modules pin prettier right
single quotes true print with hundred
and then the path to the actual file and
it should be everything else is also
again back in its place where it should
be nice and clean and oh sorry so what
we can do now is I'm just going to check
out the changes here you see we still
have this free modified files and now if
I say git commit let's just call it test
commit it starts running lint staged
with husky and here you see auto format
blah blah blah and it's also pretty fast
except for the linting four of the TS
files but other than that it should be
result in a really nice clean commit
here you see still it's the changes are
still there because it's not yet added
again to the stage changes let's see if
it's true yet No
okay now it's fruit so yeah everything
is nice and clean now and we can verify
this again to this page so yeah
everything is nice and clean committed
and that's what we want that's what we
expect yeah so for the HTML I use
jeaious beautify it's called so I was
like what the [ __ ] why is this library
courteous beautify when it does stuff
with HTML but that's something that vs
code is actually using on their own like
when you format something to be a score
it's using chess beautifier so I thought
why not stick to that and yeah the most
important feature that I like here is
that is this force aligned here that
leads to stuff being really clean being
really clean like the properties and the
eight attributes are always like a line
like this so especially when you have a
lot of stuff like that it's nice and
easily readable still so that's what I
like about this yeah and since we're
talking about HTML there's also Emmet
probably most of you know if you don't
know about it it's already implemented
by by BS code
as a standard and the way you would use
it is let's say I want to write a
container like bootstrap stuff a
container with a row with three calls
and then with the text hello angular
meetup I would do it like this the dot
is a class then I call the class
container I would make another class
called row and then I would say call
four times free because we want to have
like we're always thinking in twelve
twelve steps and then in there I would
have h2 with the content
hello angular meetup and when I expand
this now you see nicely creates your
HTML tags that you wanted and this is
also really really nice when you let's
say you want to have a lot of allies so
you have a [ __ ] ton of allies now so
this is definitely something to keep in
mind and to also work with it and use
its power yeah the next topic is already
autoprefixer in working together with
browsers list so here on the right side
sorry on the right side we have an
example of how it would look if you
would need to respect all the vendor
prefixes that there are and then
sometimes you also don't know okay what
what the hell actually what browser to
our support and and since when is the
flag required or since when is the
vendor prefix required and since when
not so what other prefix it does I used
it here for the only for the production
model because in the development panel
you should not care what because you
work in Chrome or something useful
elsewise so here it's like loading the
sass files then it's using autoprefixer
on this and then it's converting
everything to CSS and what is results
with is is depending on what you have
here in your browsers list array so this
is not what you use here but it could be
something like that so you say please
add all the vendor prefixes for the last
one major per metre version of all
browsers worldwide or here you could say
okay only browsers please that that have
a usage of one percent or more and here
you could also even specify it for every
browser individually what we have at
work is something like less to major
versions to make sure in case someone
has updated and with the rolling release
browsers it should be no problem and
then also add support for the list for
Internet Explorer Explorer versions but
that's not something to be proud of yeah
next topic is cleaning out unused CSS
out of your production bundle I think
every one of you knows okay you use some
kind of library like Foundation or
bootstrap or something else and you get
this big boilerplate code and you
probably only need some of it so you
will never really use all the capacities
of all the already predefined CSS styles
and the way you do it is you would have
your main content hash bundle CSS so
this is already basically you finished
bundle and then you would let purify CSS
run over all your HTML files look for
classes or IDs if it finds it it keeps
the classes in in the actual bundle
and if it doesn't find that it would
clean it out and you can already think
okay this is probably a problem when you
have dynamic dynamically created content
so here in the purified options
whitelist you could specify which
classes to always ignore and in this
case you see I have some boost up stuff
here and so actually you have to go for
your whole web application and see what
tricks and what doesn't
but with this with this couple classes I
was already able to make everything
runnable and be fine and here you can
see that I commented it out it's a very
both true flag and this would actually
tell you how much percent percentage of
your bundle got cleaned out and in our
case this was about thirty to forty
percent so this is definitely something
that you want to do and what's also very
handy is that purifies users also is
able to minify your CSS bundle are there
any questions so far okay so about the
terminal back workflow I see a lot of
people just using the plain old
fashioned it always pains me it always
pains me when I see that you have to go
for the history and you don't know maybe
you'll find this command or maybe you
will never find it because you typed it
on some other laptop or something so I'm
a big fan of the set shell some of you
maybe know it it's quite popular it has
like 68,000 stars and I put like the
installation guide for you on there and
also installing the all message
framework what the framework actually
does is it gives you the options to have
different themes very easily and gives
you the options to use a lot of custom
plugins and for example you can see here
what I use is the Moran theme and what I
like is when I like for example I'm I
really like to see the whole path of
where I am actually right now and what I
like of course is that it shows me the
git branch and it shows me if I have
changes in my git branch and I'm just
really I'm really quite happy with this
and what I also did here is same with
your bash RC you have here a set shell
our sieve
and again here my theme is it says here
my phim and the link also goes to all
themes that are out there and there's a
[ __ ] ton of them so you can definitely
find something that you will enjoy I
want a light one oh I think there's
light ones oh yeah no I think there is
no light one actually but this depends
of well this trip distance well when
it's feeling the functionality of it so
I guess you would still like me I set it
to background Ubuntu star so that's it
and also here I have like some examples
of the plugins that I use and again is
linking to all the plugins that are out
there there's also stuff for daca and
get aliases crazy stuff and what I
especially like is this called VD it's
called by warp directory and the way I
use this would be I type VD and then a
tab and I get all the possible war
points that I saved myself so this will
bring me to the desktop and let's say I
want to go back into the project I would
type me a front-end VDV a front-end and
I'm back again on this on this one or
like vs the backend so in this case I
would go back to via and the other thing
that's very convenient is called a less
working directory so when I make a new
tab I'm always back into what is open in
my other terminal window so these two
things I really appreciate a lot and
what I also have here is says set shell
auto suggestions and syntax highlighting
and the way you can see it here let's
say I write get status it's fine it
works but if a white get status it's
already highlights it me in red and
tells me you don't have a global library
installed that's called get and then of
course it flows to the command not found
and what I also like is that say you
have this really long commands like this
one so you already see in the like the
history auto completion is in line
basically so when I put a red arrow key
down then you you have it expanded and
you can use it so this enable
me too really easily and fast firstly
see what I have what I have written so
far like you see here I can go basic it
who are my things easily and don't have
to type in the history and look for it
or whatever yeah and I set my like
suggesting style to yellow but this can
already or this can depend on what kind
of background color you have that is
nicely for you yeah because I don't like
typing docker compose up and build I
wrote like this you and TCP into the CH
RC so this is also something you could
do like work a lot with aliases and make
some commands easier that you use
frequently yeah you probably saw by now
I'm using dishes to decode and I'm a big
fan and I don't know why there's
webstorm licenses today what I like
about vias code is that it's really nice
and transparent like you can find
anything you want on the github
repository and they release monthly
iterations of updates to their vias code
and here for example we could look into
the one for April and it and you can see
here what they have planned like all the
checkboxes here what they plan on
adapting and improving and they always
take a lot of feedback from the
community and like for example if you
notice when you do changes in in Adam
you always get it higher when you save
it you have it highlighted in yellow or
when you add some stuff to get ignore
you have it in grey like rate out and
this was not there in vs code up until
probably half a year and they said the
community said ok we want this
definitely and they made it work so they
really listened mm-hmm
to what the people actually want and you
can of course also look into the
iteration playing always and see if
there's something coming up that you're
really interested in and in case you
definitely don't want to wait there's
the insiders version and basically you
could always build a new version as soon
as they push a new commit into the
master branch of theirs so you could
install the vs code inside this version
and always be up to date but this could
also lead to breaking breaking things so
this I would only recommend if you want
to file back reports for them if you
want to contribute to two
via Skype or something like that yeah so
these are my settings so far in business
to decode so if you want to install it
blank and you want to have something up
and running already I would give this to
you so I would suggest to you something
that I like or that I think is necessary
by default
Visual Studio also gives you angular 1
suggestions in the HTML so I disabled
this and also here like again it's the
false aligned what else is there
yeah for example roads also I think this
is not very long into India's code yet
but you can actually use your BS code
capabilities to type-check
JavaScript so that's really convenient
so it will tell you you have a string
but you should use a number of stuff
like that it's also really nice when you
work on a back-end project and you
discover what errors they have in there
and what I also like is for example
let's say you're working that you have
your development branch open or your
master branch and then in the meantime
they have there were a lot of changes so
this one like it auto fetch it always
gives you the newest version of it yeah
and one thing to keep in mind if I
brought like a hint here this files
exclude on the top here so for me it was
annoying to have some files to placate
or you you only want to if you want to
if you search for index at email you
don't want to have the one in your
compiled panda stuff like that
so you only want to have the extra files
that you want to work on but what this
also does is it hides it in the file
tree of use code so what the problem I
had is there was a package lock that
always got committed and I was like
where is this package locked because I
had it excluded here and so that is for
something to keep in mind not to do yeah
here also listed for you all the plugins
that I have the extensions and yeah this
is of course opinionated so maybe you
don't need PostgreSQL or you don't need
Apache something like that and the way
you could install it is just write code
install extension flag and then the
offer name and the extension or you can
just do it with the author name or the
extension in vs code itself
yeah and one thing I like especially
much is this setting sink it scored mmm
so when you have a key topic count you
can upload your local settings and this
as let's say you work on your laptop
here and then you go back at home and
then you can easily download all the
settings again so it has all your
extensions or your settings or your key
bindings and you have it nice and clean
through a gist on github yeah some other
resources that I have here for you is
angular start the boilerplate so yeah
I'm not we're not using the angular CLI
what angular start the boilerplate this
is it's like the most most supported I
would say like ten thousand like there's
a lot of angular repos that stopped
putting out new content and updating
them because of the angular CLI but this
one is still quite popular I would say
yeah 11 days ago so that's fine and now
there right now working on upgrading it
to angular 6 and back for this of course
is like a big change again so if you
want to depend on an external
boilerplate template this would be a
good one and you had a France app I saw
actually at the door that the guy from
France is working in the first in the
upper floor so I'm a big fan of it open
it I'm actually a big fan of the France
app what this gives you it's not really
related to web development but you could
definitely improve your workflow with
all your social with the services you
use so let's say you have a slack
channel let's say you have a Trello
board or your work email something like
that you could have it easily in one
electron window and switch tabs on the
on the left side here and always be up
to date with something happened and you
don't will not miss your emails or stuff
like that because I always had to open
my Gmail in a Chrome window and then in
the convened Oh in your chrome window
you actually want to develop stuff and
it always gets tangled up so this is a
nice clean way of working or having it
separately yeah that was my talk thank
you for your attention
[Applause]